a mis espaldas puede verse un grupo de
manifestantes que protestan frente a la
casa de la ex presidenta de actual
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner se suman a muchas otras
personas que han salido a protestar este
lunes en diversos puntos de argentina no
es la primera protesta contra el
gobierno durante esta cuarentena que
comenzó el 20 de marzo pero sí
seguramente es la más grande le reclaman
al gobierno que no avance con una
reforma de la justicia que fue enviada
al poder legislativo y que dicen que es
para garantizar impunidad a funcionarios
y exfuncionarios aunque el gobierno dice
que es para mejorar el funcionamiento de
la justicia
también reclaman dicen que se está
gobernando por decreto de necesidad y
urgencia y eso atenta con contra la
estructura de la república del gobierno
señala que se trata de una situación
particular y de emergencia y algunos
también protestan directamente contra la
cuarentena porque sugieren insisten en
que no es viable y que no es necesaria
es un punto muy polémico algunos
reclaman por la situación económica
causada por
a pandemia y la cuarentena pero en
general todos coinciden en una fuerte
oposición al gobierno de hecho aunque la
convocatoria fue de tipo más bien
espontánea a través de redes sociales y
se sumaron figuras de la oposición y
llevó de hecho a una discusión dentro de
la oposición porque algunas figuras
juntos por el cambio que es el partido
opositor que fue gobierno antes de la
llegada al poder de alberto fernández
decidieron que si van a participar
mientras otros prefirieron mantener
distancia y aseguraron que no
correspondía participar de esta
manifestación veremos con los días que
van a seguir qué tipo de reacción tiene
el gobierno frente a esta manifestación